a long time ago you alright Constance  pop chocolates politican I'm a  cartoonist I live in the area and I  dress on us all about you and the other  three leaders your chocolates I break  your memoir and Glee's and I wanted you  to have it because I want to make sure  although  okay  so it's like a chicago-style  thank you all right great please thank  you  you can yep thank you  [Music]  [Music]  okay I know it's a great great  initiative a on the right kind of place  [Music]  what brings you here today  [Applause]  it's hard to speak it anywhere make sure  you vote thank you  [Applause]  you should be in the  hey there sorry to come in disrupt you  indeed I go back  [Music]  like that  thank you  that's it guys  yeah good